today on the matt walsh show we're going
to discuss the horrific murder of a
young mother in chicago the crime was
caught on tape
the footage is perhaps the worst thing
you'll ever see yet the case was ignored
by blm
and antifa as usual also five headlines
including the claim
from an aclu lawyer that jk rowling is
contributing to quote
genocide by defending biological reality
and joe biden is the subject of today's
daily cancellation uh i think this is i
don't know it's third or fourth time but
we'll keep cancelling them
as much as we need to all of that on the
way
okay we begin here you know you probably
haven't heard the name
brittany hill and if you have you
certainly haven't heard it as often or
as loudly or accompanied with as much
performative grief
as a name like george floyd or michael
brown but
the video of her death at the hands of
chicago gang members a video which came
to my attention this weekend
though it's been online for over a year
is
impossible to get out of your head once
you've seen it
the footage captured by a police
surveillance camera
i'll just describe it to you it shows
hill
standing near her car talking to two men
she's holding her one-year-old daughter
in her arms
when the car with her killers rolls up
slowly hill's daughter actually
innocently smiles and waves to the men
inside of course not knowing what's
about to happen
moments later they open fire the two men
standing with hill take off in opposite
directions
the men in the car stop get out continue
shooting
hill at some point is struck in the
abdomen she takes cover behind a parked
vehicle and lays on top of her daughter
shielding her daughter from the gunfire
the killers drive away 20 seconds later
one of the men who had been standing
with hill runs back into the frame
apparently holding a firearm
gets into his car and drives away with
hill still lying bleeding on the
pavement
20 seconds after that the other man
returns with someone else
and the two place hill in the back seat
of uh their car presumably to
bring her to the hospital and the
one-year-old girl stands up
watches as her mother is carried off um
an older man then comes and picks up the
child and takes her away now i had
originally planned
to play the video of this crime on the
show but i've decided not to do that
you can go to my twitter and watch it if
you want to
i don't want to force you to watch i'm
not going to just put it into the middle
of this
show and uh and it it it's seared into
my brain now and probably not for the
better um
i don't want to do that to you but if
you want to see it you can
now the alleged perpetrators
of this as the judge correctly called it
chilling mind-boggling and utterly
senseless crime
were arrested and charged with
first-degree murder a short time later
police say the shooting was probably
some kind of gang retaliation
though they don't believe that hill was
the intended target
uh maybe it was the men standing with
with hill i guess we can assume
this all happened over a year ago now
when it happened it made
some waves locally in the immediate
aftermath but it was
quickly forgotten even on the local
level it seems
most people across the country never
heard of it even after the dramatic and
gut-wrenching footage leaked to the
public it leaked to the public a year
ago
there were no mass protests there were
no memorial services attended by
politicians from across the country
no public officials weeping
uncontrollably over her casket as the
mayor of minneapolis did for george
floyd
and her casket speaking of which we can
assume was not plated in gold like
george floyd's was
nor is her face like george floyd's
featured on murals all over the nation
no major corporations expressed their
sorrow over her death
the democratic party didn't kneel in
silence to honor her
nobody rioted nobody looted black lives
matter didn't organize any
demonstrations on her behalf
no liberal activists or politicians told
us to quote remember her name
no laws were passed in response to her
death no calls for reform
no famous athlete said anything about
her colin kaepernick didn't say anything
nothing she just died and that was it
another statistic another tally to add
to the body count
and as far as the body count goes hill's
death
last year followed a memorial day
weekend in chicago that saw 38 shootings
and five deaths
over the weekend she was one of 490
murders in the city that year
there have been over 420 homicides
already in 2020 in chicago a year that
has seen
the most violent day in chicago in over
half a century 18 homicides
on one sunday in may but none of these
murders
or any of the hundreds of other murders
that happen in our cities every year
provoke outrage or garner attention even
remotely on par with the killings of
george floyd michael brown freddie gray
etc now the point i'm making here
has of course been made many times by
many people and for good reason
it's an important point but those who
seek to justify this disparity in
coverage and outrage
and attention have a number of responses
at the ready so i want to address
the two most common rejoinders to this
argument that i'm making right now the
point that i make
number one they'll say well in cases
like britney hill the murderers are
arrested and brought to justice so
there's no need to protest
it's true that in this specific case of
britney hill the murderers were arrested
in charge thanks in large part to the
fact that they happen to commit their
crime in full view of a surveillance
camera
but a great many murders in chicago and
elsewhere go unsolved and unprosecuted
every year
besides george floyd's killer was also
arrested and brought to justice
that you may have noticed has done
nothing whatsoever to quell the protest
the killing of jo of michael brown was
investigated on both the local
and federal level and both
investigations to include the
investigation conducted
by obama's doj cleared the officer of
wrongdoing
citing among other things eyewitness
testimony
and forensic evidence proving that
michael brown was shot while in the
process of attacking the officer and
trying to kill him trying to disarm him
this was proven but this also
did nothing to satiate the protesters
still to this day they repeat the
thoroughly and repeatedly debunked lie
that brown had his hands up and was
pleading for his life
you hear this even from the protesters
uh the george floyd pro
they still repeat this hands up don't
shoot thing
the actual outcome of these cases seems
to matter very little or not at all to
the protesters so that excuse doesn't
work
the second excuse you hear is uh well
the the protesters are speaking out
against
injustice in government they're they're
seeking certain legal and policy changes
and citizen on citizen murder is not a
matter of governmental injustice and
there's no need to call for changes to
law or policy in response to it
as the argument goes now as covered
above the problem with this
response is that the protesters are
often upset about things that do not
amount to governmental injustice michael
brown was not a matter of governmental
injustice the vast majority of police
shootings are not unjust even the
majority of police shootings
of unarmed suspects are not unjust as i
have
previously showed we talked about it on
the show last week
but even if this is about injustice or
perceived injustice
that would be all the more reason to
take this to take to the street for the
sake of the brittany hills of the world
these crime-plagued cities have been
brought to their knees
by decades of ineffectual and unjust
democratic policy
the the epidemic of violent crime in
places like chicago
is most certainly the result at least in
part
of bad laws and bad leaders who for a
start
have facilitated the collapse of the
nuclear family by cynically breeding
dependence
on welfare and other nanny state
programs um
also many of the killers who terrorize
these communities
have already been convicted of multiple
violent felonies
and yet they're still on the street they
are filtered again and again through the
court system and prison system and then
back into the community until they
finally do something
so incomprehensibly heinous that there's
no choice but to send them away for good
it was the case we talked about last
week three friends in florida
were executed in cold blood by a man who
who had over
200 felonies 15 convictions and two
stints in state prison
already under his belt this was a man
who long ago announced that he is
uninterested in becoming
and being a productive member of
civilized society he but he had to write
that message in the blood of three dead
men
for the courts to finally take him at
his word injustice
yes there's quite a lot of injustice
fueling the chaos and bloodshed in our
streets
the excuses don't hold up you know a
movement that that was really concerned
with the unjust killing of innocent
lives would be eager to stand up for
brittany hill to speak up
on her behalf to say her name and
certainly a movement that claims to
defend the dignity and value of human
life
would have quite a lot to say about
brittany hill and the many hundreds of
victims like her each year
because for all the grief i give blm the
fact is that
life matters is a message that our
culture desperately needs to hear i
agree with that
it's a message that if it was listened
to and heeded
would save many lives would probably
have saved brittany hill's life
it's just a shame that the movement
which claims to defend life
black life specifically seems in
practice to care very little for it
and that's the issue
it's it's it's very clear that in many
of these communities
you have people like the killers of
britney hill
they weren't even they as i said they
weren't even targeting her
they were going after someone else the
fact that she was standing there
and was holding her her child meant
nothing to them
they didn't care her to them her life
literally meant nothing there's almost
something
there there's um it's in a way it's
almost more chilling that she wasn't
being targeted because
because of the indifference in it okay
crime motivated by hatred
someone going to kill someone uh you
know
a a jilted lover or something killing
someone it's a it's a
horrible thing terrible
but you kind of that's something that
you can
comprehend you can contextualize that
okay someone killing out of hate and
anger and jealousy
all right people have all people have
been doing that since time in memorial
but when you find these kinds of
killings like you do so often especially
in the cities and these communities
crimes of just indifference now i don't
i don't hate you nothing against you i
just your your life just means nothing
to me i don't care
the life of your child that you're
holding means nothing to me
i feel like killing these other two guys
for some
pointless beef and you're in the way so
i'm just gonna shoot you too
whatever
though that that crime is motivated
by a total indifference
to human life so life
matters yes it black life matters all
life matters
that is an important message those
killers
tell them that
that's where the message needs to be but
these are exactly the cases that blm
antifa the left
ignores all right we're going to move on
to five headlines
[Music]
quick tip here folks if i'm ever in
possession of some kind of important
information
and uh you need to torture me to get it
out of me
which i'd prefer if you didn't but if
you needed to here's how to do it
this is the torture method that would
cause me to crack and tell you
everything i know within like five
minutes tops okay right here
the daily wire reports on august 1st hbo
sports will air
seeing america with megan rapinoe the
conversation featuring rapino
the u.s women's national soccer team
captain representative alexandria
ocasio-cortez
1619 project creator nicole hannah jones
and comedia hassan minaj
this is this is my hell this is
literally my hell dear god
horrifying better not to dwell on it
let's move on to number two
warner brothers media this is also from
the daily wire is investigating
the ellen degeneres show amid
accusations of workplace abuse according
to variety executives from telepictures
which produces ellen's show and
distributor warren brothers warner
brothers
television sent a memo to staffers last
week announcing warner media's employees
relations division and a third party
firm will be interviewing current and
former staffers
about their experience working on the
show as the daily wire reported earlier
this month
buzzfeed interviewed several former
employees of the show who claimed they
experienced a toxic work environment
counter to ellen's image as a
kind-hearted person
so um so there's been stories for years
about ellen degeneres being basically a
terrible person
who treats her subordinates like garbage
i've known this for a long time
and i'm not in the know at all and
i i don't follow celebrity celebrity
gossip very closely but even i had heard
this
so if i heard about this it's hard to
believe that warner media is
just now finding out they aren't of
course it's just that everyone else
is finding out it's it's officially
becoming common knowledge and that means
that they have to pretend to do
something
they have to pretend to care if you
haven't read the accusations against
ellen uh you can find them anywhere
online it's just what i said i mean she
treats
allegedly the people around her like
utter crap
all the time and as a diva on steroids
as the accusation goes
um some people find this this surprising
about ellen
and i i can't really see why you'd be
surprised is it because
her brand on television is that of a
friendly lovable person
is it because she brings people on the
show to perform
acts of charity for them in front of a
live studio audience you know she brings
a
whatever a kid is goes viral with some
cute video and then she brings the kid
on and interviews them and then
gives them a bunch of toys you know in
front of everybody um
is that did anyone really think that
that
that reflects her character that proves
that she's a oh
yes you're performing charity in front
of
an audience that that's clapping for you
i mean you're literally
getting a standing ovation live on the
set as you perform an act of charity
it's it's it's nice it's good for the
person who's receiving the charity i
feel good for the kid that gets all the
toys and all that kind of stuff
but it doesn't tell me anything about
you at all
um none of that even remotely tells
us about your character just because
someone's nice on tv tv with cameras
rolling doesn't mean that they're a good
person once the light switch is off
obviously
really if you if you want to find one
indicator one thing
that tells you everything you need to
know about a person's character
it's it's obviously not how they act
when the camera's on it's also not how
they treat their friends
or anything like that everybody's nice
to their friends that's the whole point
that's why they're your friends
it's how they treat people who they can
get away with
abusing so ellen can't get away with
heaping abuse on people on tv nor should
can she really do it to her fellow
celebrities people who are
on her level but she can and did
apparently direct this abuse to people
beneath her
you know interns staff etc um and
everyone no matter who you are
what position you have there are people
below you on the totem pole at least in
some situations
i mean all of us no matter how powerless
we are
usually like there are situations
throughout the day that we're in
where we have some kind of power over
another person
and if you are
an a-hole in those situations
even if it only happens briefly right
if you're an a-hole in those situations
then you're just a terrible person
if you take advantage of those power
dynamics to be the a-hole you can be
you're an awful person down the board
and we know that about you because it
doesn't matter how you
act towards your friends or how generous
or nice you are to them all that matters
as far as assessing someone's character
all that matters
is how they act towards the people they
can get away with
treating poorly that's all that matters
and i was actually thinking about this
when i was
um at the dmv last week because you know
at
dmv is a perfect example of this at the
dmv
uh is someone you know there's the woman
sitting in the booth
booth uh the boof sure there's the woman
sitting in the booth
across from you and you're doing
whatever changing registrations getting
a license whatever it is
she has enormous power over you in
in that situation now as soon as you
leave she doesn't really but
when you're sitting there she's got a
she has you in her grasp
and if she wants to make your life
miserable she can do it
and the reason people hate the dmv is
that some dmv employees
enjoy taking advantage of that power
dynamic of that momentary grasp they
have on you
and do they do exactly that they just
make your life miserable for no apparent
reason
but i was thinking about this because
the woman that i was dealing with
at the dmv last week was the opposite
she was super friendly and kind
and was uh was trying to help me so that
the dmv process was as painless as
possible you know
and i thought to myself wow this is a
very good person i
i'm interacting with her for a few
minutes i don't know anything about her
don't even know her name i i could tell
you this is a good person 100
just because of of this right here she
doesn't have to
be this nice but she is
so um that's how you can assess people's
character and that's why
in conclusion ellen degeneres is
terrible number three nick sandman
the covington catholic student who was
slandered all over the media reached a
settlement in his defamation suit
against the washington post this week
this after reaching a settlement with
cnn a few months ago
but cnn is not done defaming him it
seems brian stelter cnn anchor
retweeted a tweet from a lawyer named
mark zaid
and the tweet said those with zero legal
experience as far as i can tell should
not be conjecturing on lawsuits they
know nothing about what kind of
journalism is that
i've litigated defamation suits uh
defamation cases
sandman was undoubtedly paid nuisance
value settlement and nothing more
well so stelder didn't say that but he
did retweet it
and salmon's lawyer lynn wood says that
this could easily breach cnn's
confidentiality agreement because they
aren't allowed to discuss the terms
of the settlement yet here's stelter
maybe i guess he would argue not
discussing it but but
uh amplifying someone who is
and discussing it through a proxy in
effect and wood indicates that
that it's he's lying anyway uh that the
claim isn't true
so they're just
you can only imagine how angry
these the people at washington post and
cnn are
um and how much they hate this kid
how much they absolutely hate him they
are they are
overcome with hate because they're not
used to this
this isn't how it's supposed to go they
slander and defame people all the time
especially speaking of power dynamics
especially focusing on people don't have
any power to fight back
and they thought that's what they were
doing here you know they
consider it from from from their
perspective you know you almost feel
sorry for them
well not really but they've been doing
this for so long just defaming people it
doesn't matter
painting people as racist just you know
just destroying people's life
casually like it's nothing and um
and all of a sudden out of nowhere
they figure okay well you know here
we've got a case just a bunch of high
school kids white high school kids
we could do this to them well you know
no big deal we'll destroy their lives
get some clicks out of it
uh virtue signal a little bit their
lives are destroyed we move on
this is the process this is what we do
and then nick sandman comes out of
nowhere and actually fights back
and wins these these poor people at cnn
and washington post
they're really the victims here they're
the victims because they weren't able to
victimize someone else or at least they
victimized someone else and
then they got they got hit back in the
nose number four an aclu lawyer named
chase
strangio has uh accused jk rowling of
contributing to genocide
by arguing that uh because you know jk
rowling has
argued that biological sex exists that
that's really her
entire argument um she's not even
despite what we hear now
she she is far from a conservative
on gender issues or on any issue at all
the only thing she has said on
when it comes to transgenderism that the
left doesn't like is just that
biological sex exists
but that's of course enough to make her
um
not just evil but genocidal so chase
strangio has said that
she is contributing to genocide let me
read let me read this diatribe from uh
stranger this is what it says okay
this is part of it anyway it would be
nice to ignore the harry potter person
but the rhetoric being used on her
massive platform
is feeding a genocidal impulse that
already exists in government and within
individuals
she is dangerous situating the trans
subject and the trans body in the
contested discursive space the way she
does
pulls the conversation around transness
into the posture
of working to locate the legitimate
trans subject
did you get that okay the i the idea
being that we must defend against the
allegation that too many trans people in
the world reflects a problem that is
after all her point and in so doing we
see the conversation to assist people in
institutions
and perhaps most insiduously in so doing
we give the false impression that sexed
bodies
are things only trans people have by
obscuring the larger structural impulses
behind
bodily policing and the violence of the
sex binary we ensure that
the continuation of these structures
okay now
first of all there is no genocide of
trans people happening
that should go without saying this
person is making that up
uh i mean unless you count the treatment
of lgbt people
in in muslim countries if that's what
we're talking about
then all right maybe you've got a case
but something tells me that old strangio
here
is not intending for this to be uniquely
a criticism of muslim societies
or a criticism of muslim societies at
all
something tells me in fact that as far
as this person is concerned we would
just
when talking about the plight of lgbt
people in the world we would just skip
over
muslim countries entirely and focus
completely on what's happening in the
west
but in any case genocide or not
defending biology does not amount to
genocide or contribute to it or feed it
okay but really i want you to focus on
the ridiculous lengths this person is
going
to make the anti-science position seem
intelligent and scholarly
situating the trans subject and the
trans body in the contested discursive
space
the way she does pulls the conversation
around transits into posturing
into the posture of working to locate
the legitimate trans subject
that sentence uses about 30 words and
loads of jargon to communicate something
that could be conveyed simply in about
10 words
and and and and don't be fooled by this
okay this is the mark of an
of an unintelligent person who wants to
seem intelligent
truly intelligent people who have
legitimate points to make
make them in ways that are clear and
easy to understand
that's what a really intelligent a
really intelligent person
can understand jargony concepts
okay that's that's one level of
intelligence is to understand what's
being said
the next level real intelligence is
being able to convey and communicate it
stripped of the jargon in a
straightforward simple way
if you can't do that then it tells me
you're not really that smart or it tells
me you're a pompous ass
who is who maybe could be more clear but
you're being unclear intentionally
to show off your intelligence so either
way um
either way it's it's you know in this
case it's kind of a defense mechanism
uh because okay and it works
right i have to have to hand it to them
in a way it works
because they use a lot of academic
jargon
especially when it comes to the gender
ideology on the left
all in service of the claim that men can
have babies
essentially all of this everything you
just heard
is in service to the claim that a man
can get pregnant
which is to call that a dumb position
would be an insult to stupidity
this is a delusional insane position
but they trick some people into thinking
that their position is smart and sciency
just by putting in a lot of scholarly
jargon and all of that
uh number five finally here's the san
francisco weekly i'm just gonna i'm just
gonna give you their
the caption um it says surfing
surfing despite its roots in indigenous
pacific islander history
has been seen as a sport for straight
white men for far too long
okay so now surfing is racist too just
just wanted to update you on that
surfing is racist um
and i just want to say about that to be
clear
okay i
agree and i think we need to repeal the
laws
prohibiting non-white people from buying
surfboards and going to the ocean
i i didn't know that law existed
if it does i say it's it's 20 20.
let's get rid of it i will take that
stand right now so thank you to the san
francisco weekly
we are we are together in this movement
um
and that's your five headlines we're
gonna get to our daily cancellation in
just a second but before we do
you know if you haven't got your readers
passed yet i mean what are you doing
with your life what are you doing with
your time
uh why uh why do you hate
us and me specifically i take it as a
personal offense to me
but really you're only hurting yourself
you only have this this hurts you more
than it hurts me okay
99 cents is all it takes for the first
year three dollars a month
uh is is is the price going forward if
you get a reader's pass
uh and and the thing with the rear pass
is that you're getting the real story
stripped of all the leftist spin and
everything
and you can get exclusive op-eds from us
your podcast host you can get uh
great analysis from our guest writers
in-depth analysis from our daily wire
reporter so we're all fantastic
the membership tier is already a bargain
at three dollars a month but like i said
you get your first month for 99 cents
you also get access to our mobile app
you receive push notifications for
breaking news and special content
as well as you can join the community of
daily wire members who are actively
commenting and discussing our content
with each other
um that is mobile ad free access to all
the daily wire news exclusive op-eds
and all of our podcasts on our mobile
app for the low price of one dollar go
to
dailywire.com subscribe and join today
now for our daily cancellation we're
gonna be canceling joe biden and this is
not his first cancellation of course
won't be his last
the fact that i have to cancel some
people so many times may lead you to
believe that my cancellations are rather
ineffective and uh even pointless you
might say but if you think that
then you are also canceled stop picking
on me you bully
um anyway so joe biden is cancelled for
something that he
he tweeted yesterday this is this tweet
it says the hard truth is women and
particularly women of color
have never had a fair shot to get ahead
in this country that's why today i'm
releasing my plan
to make sure women can fully participate
in our economy and country
and then then he has his link to his
plan his very important plan
for women now i like how there are a
couple things here i like how the phrase
the hard truth has has become a
euphemism for lie
you hear this a lot from politicians the
hard truth is this
and then what follows invariably is a
steaming load of horse manure
no lies are not hard truths they might
they might be hard to disguise as the
truth if that's what you mean
i i'm working very hard to make you
believe this is the truth maybe that's
the meaning in which case
okay but that's not a hard truth the
other thing
uh that that you take from the statement
of joe biden's is just how
broad and lazy the victim culture has
become in our country
women don't get a fair shot to get ahead
in this country what
women are we talking about the same
people here women
i mean you never know these days the
left they don't even know what a woman
is so you never know but
women actually have a very fair shot to
get ahead too fair if anything
women are ahead already in most in
almost every meaningful metric
men are less likely to have college
degrees more likely to drop out of high
school
more likely to be suspended or expelled
more likely to be homeless
more likely to be drug addicts more
likely to be homicide victims more
likely to commit suicide more likely to
get injured on the job
more likely to go to prison in fact
women get lighter sentences for the same
crimes in federal court
um so that means the court system favors
women the education system favors women
due to a form
affirmative action and other factors
employers favor women
women have all the rights men have and
some rights men don't have
women for example here's a big one have
soul say over whether to kill their
child in the womb or not
they are judge jury and executioner over
human life
legally women not only have the chance
to get ahead but
are ahead and thanks in large part to
the fact that every system favors them
and often drastically so
and this is one of the reasons why the
feminist movement has become so insane
and fractured and weird in this country
there's just no use for it they have
nothing to do modern america is already
everything a feminist could want and
then some
except that feminists want women to be
persecuted
and they're not that and that's what
really upsets them that is the one thing
that is the one additional thing they
want
they want everything they want all the
advantages and privileges that they have
but they also want to be persecuted on
top of it because persecution being able
to claim persecution in victimhood
is the ultimate privilege and uh so that
is the last thing that they are
clamoring for and uh they can't get it
this is the irony here they clamored for
every privilege
known to man uh or in this case known to
woman
and got it and because of that they
can't get the final thing which is the
victimhood they so
desperately creep so uh yes women are
ahead can get ahead
i think joe biden knows that i mean at
this point who knows what he knows and
doesn't know
or if he even understands what he's
saying but um
joe biden is canceled for that lazy and
ridiculous bit of pandering
and uh we'll throw in feminists or
cancel two just
just because we'll cancel them again but
that goes without saying during every
cancellation the feminists are canceled
as well
um and so there it is sorry about that
joe
we'll leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
2020.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there
you